maillot une pièce au nombre moi je suis
pour
pourquoi pour le maillot c'est ce qu'ont
succès cents à fait normal je suis pas
pourquoi je suis content évidemment vous
savez
qu'est ce que c'est indécent malgré tout
1 et vous attendent alors oui ça
d'accord ça je suis pour
pourquoi on sait au moins on sait au
moins ce qu'on a devant soi quoi contre
le maillot une pièce pour le noyau il
est pas mal quoi enfin pour des plages
comme la baule c'est un peu cru pour la
liberté chacun lors je serais plutôt
contre voyez vous parce que quand même
une certaine esthétique qui manque les
couleurs et tout ça non je suis tout à
fait contre pour support pour les filles
sont bien commencé leur vin pour ou
contre le maillot de bain une pièce
c'est pas ça dépend des femmes il aborde
en herbe n'ont jamais vu à l'appui à me
faire une opinion avant de voir reçu
bourg
pour mel alors qu'à peine limites quand
même lesquels à ce qu'ils sont capables
de pouvoir le porter et qui sont bien je
suis pour pour regarder j'ai inscrit
mais j'aurai une fiancée je voudrais pas
je suis moi aussi je suis contre mal
pourquoi parce que
j'estime que cette année ça a contraint
pour la pudeur pour commencer un
promener les seins à l'air sur une plage
bar rock c'est quand même
[Musique]
ceci pour pour la pluie je suis content
pour ma femme tout au moins mais pour
les autres ça dépendrait pourquoi
pourquoi je suis content
et bien parce que je pense que la
plupart de ceux qui s'exhibe ray avec ce
maillot là ne serait peut-être pas les
plus belles à voir à moi c'est pour ça
me plairait pas mais enfin a quand même
à aa la paye sa chère mademoiselle elle
vous pour contre le maillot une pièce
[Musique]
pourquoi
c'est le temps je crois que toutes les
figures une jolie poitrine dans l'enfant
intérieur sont vos journaux ce compte
pourquoi c'est ridicule pour une pièce
pourquoi êtes-vous avatar ce qu'elle
fait c'est mieux
la femme est bien plus chic dans un
maillot une pièce
une pièce
et pas le 201 cours
pourquoi une pièce oui j'ai vous
pourquoi parce que c'est préconise-t-il
on va décoller c'est non c'est génial de
ski respectueux pour la personne elle
même et pour les autres
à dire sa mission même si c'est très
joli sigle vendre le maillot une pièce
pourquoi parce qu'il est de lui-même il
est déjà pas très joli je suis contre un
maillot une pièce pourquoi parce que
c'est gênant mais beaucoup plus à l'aise
de pièces non pourquoi
parce que je pense qu'il faut être deux
peut-être que si j'étais jeune et puis
c'était bien fait évidemment pourquoi la
changer pourquoi parce qu'il n'est pas
convenable
bonjour madame redonner rapidement le
prix de ce maillot s'il vous plaît 66
prendre 66 francs est ce que vous vendez
le deux pièces moins une comment le
voulait nuire en fois du tout on a deux
noms n'ont d'ailleurs écouter ce n'est
pas bon cela charme avec à bon et vous
n'avez pas l'impression que ça prendra à
la boule et bill savait que mode
remarqué ce soit les deux pièces d'une
d'ailleurs sa recette à ce moment là
vous parlez et l'allemand ou voilà est
pas pour cela vous avez des enfants
voyons pas de miroir d'en avoir dans
l'annulation de mayol même pas la main
c'est l'adjoint comment réagit la
municipalité de la bonne à cette mode du
2e - d'une c'est une question
d'actualité
elle a déjà été posée et je vais vous
répondre
son prendre la paternité de la réponse
qui a été fait quelqu'un avait posé la
question à l'entourage de monsieur le
maire et il a été répondu d'une façon
très spirituel il certain qu'en
l'occurrence le sénateur maire ne
saurait faire mais lisible